>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Applause ]
>> Elizabeth Pugh: The quality
of mercy is not strained.
It droppeth as the gentle rain
from heaven upon the place beneath.
It is twice blessed.
It blessed him that
gives and him that takes.
From Portia from The
Merchant of Venice.
Good evening, Justice Ginsburg,
esteemed guests, ladies
and gentlemen.
I welcome you to the
Coolidge Auditorium
for tonight's very
special performance.
My name is Elizabeth Pugh
and I am honored to serve
as the General Counsel for
the Library of Congress.
Our Law Librarian, Jane Sanchez,
could not be with us this evening,
so I'm thrilled to be able to
open tonight's event on behalf
of the Law Library of Congress.
The Law Library is the custodian
of the world's largest collection
of legal materials, with nearly
three million items and counting,
in numerous languages and formats.
The Law Library serves
all three branches
of the United States
government, the practicing bar,
state and local governments,
American businesses, scholars
and the world legal community.
Throughout the year the Law Library
presents many public programs
focused on current legal topics.
Coming this fall look out for
events celebrating Constitution Day,
Human Rights Day, as well
as the Kellogg Biennial
Lecture on Jurisprudence.
Tonight's performance
is the last of a series
of three events commemorating
the 500th anniversary
of the establishment of the
Jewish Ghetto in Venice, Italy.
The Law Library previously
held two lectures.
The first one in 2016 entitled The
City of the Jews: Segregated Space
and the Admission of Strangers
in the Jewish Ghetto of Venice,
and another this past February
Understanding Seclusion:
the Legal Dimensions of the Ghetto.
You can find videos of
both of these events
on the Law Library's
YouTube channel.
This event tonight was made
possible by a generous donation
to the Library of Congress from
the American's Sephardi Federation.
The Library also gratefully
recognizes a contribution received
through the Friends
of the Law Library
of Congress from Thomas Reuters.
An additional support was
provided by Mr. Robert S. Roth,
Jr. This mock trial was
staged last year in Venice,
Italy as part of the city's
500th anniversary commemorations.
We are fortunate that
the coordinator
for last year's event
agreed to reprise his role
for us in the United States.
For his efforts to produce
tonight's performance I would
like to recognize Dick
Schneider, Associate Dean
for International Affairs
and Professor of Law
at Wake Forest University
School of Law.
[ Applause ]
And the only male judge
on our bench tonight.
>> Richard Schneider: Yes.
[inaudible].
>> Elizabeth Pugh: And let me
introduce the distinguished cast.
Arguing on behalf of
Portia, Teresa Miguel-Stearns
of the Lillian Goldman Law
Library of Yale Law School.
[ Applause ]
Arguing on behalf of Antonio and the
Republic of Venice, Eugene Gulland
of Covington and Burling.
[ Applause ]
And arguing on behalf of Shylock,
Michael Klotz of Jones Day.
[ Applause ]
And now our distinguished
panel of judges.
Micaela del Monte of the European
Parliament Research Service.
[ Applause ]
Suzanne Reynolds, Dean of Wake
Forest University School of Law.
[ Applause ]
Dick Schneider also of Wake
Forest University School of Law
[ Applause ]
Ambassador Connie Morella.
And the judge who needs
no introduction,
but I'm going to say it.
The judge who will deliver the
final verdict, Associate Justice
of the Supreme Court of the United
States, Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
[ Applause ]
And, finally, the man
playing, finally,
playing the man whose fate hangs in
the balance is Ed Gero as Shylock.
[ Applause ]
I think he'll appear later.
Before we get to the trial you
will hear from two speakers.
David Dangoor of the American
Sephardi Federation will help us
understand the history of the
Sephardic Jews, their connection
to Venice and the Diaspora.
Michael Kahn of the Shakespeare
Theatre Company will refresh our
memories on the plot of The
Merchant in Venice in order
to help frame the scene that
you will see on tonight's stage.
And then, after the judges
take recess for deliberations,
you will hear from Professor Jim
Shapiro of Columbia University,
who will go into more
depth about The Merchant
of Venice during Shakespeare's time.
So before the performance
begins I'd like to remind you
to kindly switch your mobile phones
and other devices to
the silent mode.
And please note that tonight's
program is being recorded
as a Facebook live stream,
and for later presentation
on the Law Library's
YouTube channel.
And now I would like to invite
David Dangoor to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> David Dangoor: Thank
you, ladies and gentlemen.
On behalf of the American Sephardi
Federation I'm very pleased
to be able to stand in front
of you, and be a sponsor
of today's interesting event.
And obviously it's a great
honor for us to be associated
with this distinguished panel
of judges and judge Ginsburg.
I will very briefly just
tell you something in context
about this play, and the
importance to Jewish history.
The American Sephardi
Federation is an organization
that is strictly cultural
and historic.
And we study the history, and we
preserve and promote the history,
of what I'll call the Unknown Jews.
There's a very large contingent of
Jews that come from the Middle East,
the Far East, North
Africa, and originally some
of them from Spain and Portugal.
They are largely forgotten
in history today.
And you will see why we want to
be associated with this event.
We represent the Jewish
history of all these Jews
from the Iberian Peninsula,
the Balkans, the Middle East,
North Africa, the Far East, and
importantly early American history.
The Jews came here very early
via mainly the Caribbean.
So it's, therefore, a special
pleasure today on behalf
of the American Sephardi
Federation to convey that we have
since long adopted
Shylock of The Merchant
of Venice as a Sephardic Jew.
I.e., a Jew originating
from the mass exodus of Jews
from the Iberian Peninsula, and
in his case likely from Spain.
A specific history that
we at the Federation guard
and study among several
other Jewish histories.
There are hints in
the Shakespeare play
that this very well probably
is a Sephardic Jew from Spain.
Before I explain, allow
me first to outline why
in some way the play The Merchant
of Venice is to be viewed as a gift
to the Jewish people by Shakespeare.
This is the perspective.
Because of the understandable
enormous historical
and social attention to the
horrors of the Holocaust,
there's little focus and
interest to remind us today
of the terrible plight in
Europe for the Jewish people
from the latter half of the Middle
Ages throughout the early modern
period, culminating
in the Holocaust,
and the failed mass attack
in attempt to drive the Jews
into the Mediterranean in 1948.
Because of the brilliance and fame
of Shakespeare, and the brilliance
of his play, The Merchant of
Venice functions as a reminder
of the long-standing and violent
justice toward the Jewish people.
This will continue to help to
revisit earlier Jewish history.
Including, for example,
the slaughter of the innocent large
Jewish communities along the Rhine
River in Europe, Southern France,
of the detestable Inquisition
with burnings at the stake,
[inaudible] and mass [inaudible]
in Spain, Portugal and it's
sideshows in Sicily and Venice,
and many other parts
of the Mediterranean.
At the time of Shakespeare
writing the play,
there still were many
show tribes of Jews
and so-called converses,
including in Venice.
And in England at the
time, to use a later term,
England was [inaudible]
following their expulsion in 1290
in the Elizabethan era
which was very anti-Jewish.
Jews were only allowed back
in 1656 under Cromwell,
some 60 years after
The Merchant of Venice.
In summary, wearing a historical
hat, it's noteworthy that the play
at the time only deals with
basically financial matters,
and not something much worse, which
would have been typical of the day.
In other words, for this reason and
the famous monologue in the play,
optimistically viewed, maybe
this is one of the early European
and English attempts
to humanize Jews.
The next attempt in
England really only came
with Sir Walter Scott's widely
popular novel Ivanhoe in 1820
with Rebecca and her father
being among the lead characters,
perhaps even paving the way
for the Israeli's ascendance
as Prime Minister in
England in 1868,
200 years after The
Merchant of Venice.
The Venetian Ghetto, where Jews had
to live, was constituted in 1516
as you heard, only 14 years after
the Spanish Inquisition in 1492.
Several very wealthy Sephardic
Jewish trading families fled
to Venice, where Jews had been
allowed to live more freely
in the Venetian Republic.
There's little doubt that the
ghetto, with its strict boundaries,
was a result of the Inquisition
fever sweeping the rounds
of the Catholic Church.
The Ghetto was divided
into two areas--
the Ghetto Nuovo, the New Ghetto,
and the adjacent Ghetto
Vecchio, the Old Ghetto.
These names of the Ghetto
sections are misleading
as actually the Ghetto
Nuovo is the older one.
A large number of Jews
from different backgrounds
came to live in the Ghetto.
But over time they never developed
a distinct Venetian identity.
Instead they continued strongly
to identify with their origins.
Therefore, four of the five
synagogues were clearly divided
according to ethnic identity in
the Ghetto-- the German Synagogue,
the Italian Synagogue, the
Spanish and Portuguese Synagogue,
and the Levantine Synagogue.
There was a fifth synagogue,
the so-called Canton Synagogue,
but that was built specifically
for private use by four families.
The languages spoken at the time
in the Ghetto included Venetian,
Italian, Judeo Spanish, Judeo
Arabic, Spanish, French and German,
while Hebrew was traditionally
used on signage, inscriptions
and for official purposes, as
well as wedding contracts and,
of course, in religious services.
Allow me, finally, a quick
background on the word "ghetto."
Like with so much about the play
there are different explanations
and theories about the
origins of the word.
Some say the word originates
from the foundries in Venice,
where the Italian word "getto"
is very similar to "ghetto."
But it's most likely that
the word "ghetto" derives
from the Gothic word
"gatto," which means street.
And the reasoning for that is the
Jews throughout the Middle Ages
usually congregated along one street
where they would have all their Jew,
all their shops and
places of commerce.
So it was very easy to decide
to enclose a street like that,
and put up boundaries,
and make it into a ghetto.
The strict confinement of the
Jews and Venetian Ghetto ended
with an edict by the
28-year-old Napoleon
in 1797 following his conquest and
dissolving of the Venetian Republic.
That's what you need to know.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Kahn: Good evening.
I've been given the task
of explaining to you a play
that I think you've
all seen and read.
But I've been told to maybe
refresh your minds about the story.
Just let me tell you that it
was first published in 1600.
And that Shakespeare, as much
of the time, took the stories
that he had read, that
were written earlier.
One was the story of
the bond of flesh,
and the other was the
story of the caskets.
Now The Merchant of Venice, we very
often confuse the fact we think
because Shylock is such
a vibrant character,
we think that The Merchant
of Venice is Shylock.
But indeed he's not.
He is the real Merchant of
Venice, Antonio, a trader.
In the beginning of the play we find
Antonio with several of his friends,
young men among whom are
Bassanio and Lorenzo.
Bassanio has come to Antonio
admitting that he has spent a lot
of Antonio's money trying to better
himself, and also buying a lot
of very good items and clothes
that have made him a
great man about town.
But he tells Antonio that he has
the possibility of repaying all
of that money again, because he has
found a beautiful heiress living
on an island outside of
Venice who is named Portia,
and he wishes to vie
for her in marriage.
Antonio, who says he doesn't have
very much money at the moment,
but says, "For you
I want to do this."
And he goes to the only place
that he can get this money,
and that is to Shylock,
who lends money.
Shylock tells him first,
of course, of how badly he
and his fellow Jews have been
treated by the Christians of Venice,
and yet they come to him for money.
But he says, "I will do this."
And in the process of this
negotiation he says, "You know,
I am not going to charge
you anything.
I just want if you do not repay me
in a merry jest let me say I will
take a pound of your flesh to be cut
from wherever in your body I wish."
Antonio, who has been
a successful merchant,
finds this actually
a charitable request,
because it's basically impossible.
And he comes home with the money.
And Bassanio goes off
to Belmont to Portia.
There is another friend of
Shylock that we should mention.
And that is young Lorenzo.
Lorenzo has seen and become
attracted to, and perhaps fallen
in love with, a young Jewess who
lives in the Ghetto, Jessica.
Jessica is Shylock's daughter.
At one point in the
play, rather early on,
Lorenzo abducts Jessica quite
willingly, who leaves the Ghetto
and her father with a
great deal of his money.
Shylock is deeply, deeply,
deeply distressed by this.
Antonio's ventures at sea
proved to be disastrous.
The ships are wrecked.
And Antonio cannot pay Shylock back.
This comes very soon after Shylock
has, his daughter has been stolen.
And Shylock demands that the
bond be paid, and that the pound
of flesh be taken from
Antonio's body.
There is a great trial, which
will be discussed tonight.
And in that trial Portia
arrives dressed as a man,
and pretends to be a lawyer, and
eventually wins Antonio's suit.
And Shylock is not only
asked to give up his money,
but he's also asked and told he
must be baptized as a Christian
at the end of this trial.
There is one more act of this
play where everybody goes back
to Belmont, and seems to get along
very well in some productions.
In other productions not so well.
But it is why Shylock,
who ends the fourth act,
the fifth act is Belmont, and that
is why this play is always put
as one of Shakespeare's comedies,
because it seems to
have a happy ending.
But there is no question that
the resonant issue of this play,
and the largest character
display, is Shylock and his fate.
And that's what we're going
to talk about tonight.
[ Applause ]
>> Edward Gero: Good evening.
In his first speech Shylock
expresses his surprise
at Antonio's request for a loan.
Senor Antonio, many a time and oft
in the Rialto you have rated me
about my moneys and my usances.
Still have I borne it
with a patient shrug,
for suffering is the
badge of all our tribe.
You call me misbeliever,
cut-throat dog,
and spit upon my Jewish gabardine.
And all for use of
that which is mine own.
Well then, it now appears
you need my help.
Go to, then.
You come to me, and you say,
"Shylock, we would have moneys."
You say so.
You, did void your rheum
upon my beard and foot me
as you spurn a stranger
cur over your threshold.
Moneys is your suit.
What should I say to you?
Should I not say, "Hath a dog money?
Is it possible a cur
can lend 3,000 ducats?"
Or shall I bend low and in a
bondman's key, with bated breath
and whispering humbleness
say this, "Fair sir,
you spit on me on Wednesday last.
You spurned me such a day.
Another time you called me dog.
And for these courtesies I'll
lend you thus much moneys?"
In the next speech, Shylock
is discussing the terms
of the forfeiture of his
loan should Antonio default.
And he reveals what he
values in a pound of flesh.
To bait fish withal.
If it will feed nothing else
it will feed my revenge.
He hath disgraced me, and
hindered me half a million,
laughed at my losses, mocked
at my gains, scorned my nation,
thwarted my bargains, cooled my
friends, heated mine enemies.
And what's his reason?
I am a Jew.
Hath not the Jew eyes?
Hath not the Jew hands
organs, dimensions,
senses, affections, passions?
Fed with the same food,
hurt with the same weapons,
subject to the same diseases, healed
by the same means, warmed and cooled
by the same winter and
summer as a Christian is?
If you prick us, do we not bleed?
If you tickle us, do we not laugh?
If you poison us, do we not die?
And if you wrong us,
shall we not revenge?
If we are like you in the rest,
we will resemble you in that.
If a Jew wrong a Christian,
what is his humility?
Revenge. If a Christian wrong a Jew,
what should his sufferance
be by Christian example?
Why, revenge.
The villainy you teach
me, I will execute.
And it shall go hard.
But I will better the instruction.
And lastly, Shylock argues
in court against using mercy
to temper justice, in the hopes
of receiving the same kindness
in God's final judgment.
What judgment shall I
dread, doing no wrong?
You have among you many a purchased
slave, which like your asses
and your dogs and mules,
you use in abject
and in slavish parts,
because you bought them.
Shall I say to you,
"Let them be free.
Marry them to your heirs.
Why sweat they under burdens?
Let their beds be made
as soft as yours.
And let their palates be
seasoned with such viands."
You will answer, "The
slaves are ours."
So do I answer you.
The pound of flesh, which I
demand of him, is dearly bought.
Tis mine. And I will have it.
If you deny me, fie upon your law.
There is no force in
the decrees of Venice.
I stand for judgment.
Answer. Shall I have it?
[ Applause ]
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: We will
now proceed with Shylock's appeal.
And before we do so,
let me caution Counsel
that the bench is having
great difficulty hearing,
so if you might tip the podium
slightly, and speak very distinctly.
We will hear first
from Shylock's Counsel.
>> Michael Klotz: Good
afternoon, your honors.
I'm Michael Klotz, Counsel
for the Appellant, Shylock.
Before I begin I'd like to
reserve two minutes for rebuttal.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: You may.
>> Michael Klotz: There are two
central issues in this appeal.
The first issue is whether a party
that's entered into agreement,
and hasn't fulfilled
its obligations,
is able to keep the
fruits of the agreement.
My client, Shylock, entered into
a loan agreement for 3,000 ducats.
And the ducats were
lent to Bassanio.
And Antonio was the
guarantor for that loan.
And it was for a term
of three months.
And the loan came due.
And the money was not repaid.
And to this day Antonio
continues to hold the money.
And no interest has been paid.
And my client has been out of luck.
The second issue in this appeal
is whether a non-citizen who goes
to a court and requests a
legal judgment can in doing
so commit a criminal act.
And that's what my client
has been convicted of.
Shylock went to the court, and
asked to have the contract enforced.
And he asked specifically to have
the penalty provision enforced.
And unbeknownst to him, Portia
was disguised as a judge.
And she's not a judge.
And she issued a judgment.
She issued a judgment against him.
And she found that he violated
the Alien Act, which protects
against any non-citizen attempting
to take the life of a citizen.
And, so, in making this
appeal to the court saying,
"Please give me the money that's due
under this agreement," Portia said
that this was attempted murder.
And our argument on that
issue is that can't be.
It can't be the case that when
somebody goes to a court and asks
for justice that that's a crime.
So we ask that the judgment
be reversed without retrial.
We ask for the money to come back.
We're asking for interest,
and any other relief
that the court deems fit.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: I'd like
clarification on two points.
One, are you demanding
the pound of flesh,
or have you relinquished
that request?
>> Michael Klotz: Your Honor,
we're relinquishing that request,
but we believe that that aspect of
the contract was valid and legal.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: So you are
not demanding a pound of flesh.
You're demanding your
return of your money.
You said interest.
But I think the record shows
that at the time this loan was
negotiated you said not a doit
of usance for money.
You were giving the money and
you were not demanding interest.
You were demanding only
the pound of flesh.
Is it not true that you
relinquished any claim to interest?
>> Michael Klotz: Your Honor,
in that same negotiation
my client referenced
that when the loan came due that
he would be given such sum or sums
as are due under the agreement.
So I think it would be up to the
court to examine the contract,
and determine whether
there's prejudgment interest.
The prejudgment interest is for
the three-month period of the loan.
And the post-judgment interest is
from when the loan
came due until today.
[ Laughter ]
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
There's another unusual
feature of this proceeding.
Antonio is surety.
The beneficiary of
the loan is Bassanio.
But you are not suing Bassanio.
You brought a suit against Antonio.
>> Michael Klotz: That's
correct, Your Honor.
He was the guarantor on the
loan, and he was the recipient
with the Republic of
Venice of the money,
the underlying money
for this agreement.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: Even
though you knew full well
that Bassanio had the
wherewithal to pay back the loan.
And then there would be
no claim against Shylock.
>> Michael Klotz: You're
correct, Your Honor.
We chose the Defendants to sue.
And we didn't sue Bassanio.
>> Richard Schneider: Counsel,
why is it that you're asking
for the money now when
you were offered the money
at trial and refused it?
>> Michael Klotz: Well, our
position has changed, Your Honor.
[ Laughter ]
At trial we were requesting
specific performance.
And it wasn't given to us.
And then we then asked
for the money.
And we were we were told
that that was impossible.
Portia interpreted the
contract in a way that,
as I believe the court will
realize, is totally improper.
She interpreted the agreement
to allow a pound of flesh,
but to allow no blood
and absolutely no more
or less than a pound of flesh.
So she interpreted the agreement in
a way that it couldn't be performed.
>> Suzanne Reynolds: Mr. Klotz,
what role do you think Portia's
deception plays in this proceeding?
>> Michael Klotz: Portia's
deception is egregious.
She's not an attorney.
She was not a judge.
She was not a part of any court.
She obviously misrepresented
who she was.
And I think, perhaps most
significantly, she was married
to Bassanio, who Justice
Ginsburg has pointed
out was the obligor on the loan.
So she had a direct financial
interest in the outcome.
[ Laughter ]
>> Suzanne Reynolds: And
what specific defense does
that give your client?
>> Michael Klotz: Well, I mean
if she was actually a judge she
should have recused herself.
And because she was not a judge
the judgment is completely void
and invalid.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
Should you need a defense.
You're the plaintiff in this suit.
>> Michael Klotz: Excuse me?
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: Shylock
was the plaintiff suing --
>> Michael Klotz: Correct.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: Antonio.
>> Connie Morella: What
about the role of revenge?
We hear Shylock repeating
that in many different ways,
so that he was revenge and
is connected to his intent.
So his intent was for
a very fatalistic,
you know, ending for Antonio.
How do you fit that into saying that
you are trying to defend Shylock?
>> Michael Klotz: Shylock
has been misunderstood.
And the point of revenge,
it's true that my client
and Antonio were not
the best of friends.
But he had two other motives in
pursuing the penalty provision.
And he made that very clear
during the proceeding.
And one of those points
that he was seeking is
to finally have the chance to
have some rights under the law.
So the Alien Act as
an example of a law
that punishes non-citizens
in a disparate manner.
As we've heard a little bit
already Jewish citizens were forced
to live in the Ghetto.
They had a curfew.
They could only take
certain occupations.
They actually had to pay to
have the Ghetto patrolled.
But, as the court is aware,
freedom of contract is one
of these great things where,
whatever the generally applicable
law is, two people can sit down
and agree-- this is what you
will do, this is what I will do,
and they make their
own law essentially.
And, so, my client was
very angry and very upset,
when in this one aspect of his
life that he could control,
his rights were not
being recognized.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
We heard that Shylock was
in a state of extreme distress.
Are you making any plea
that he would be incompetent
to have been accused of a criminal
action, because he was so distraught
at his daughter's elopement, and
her theft of his worldly goods?
>> Michael Klotz: Your
Honor, we're not arguing
that Shylock was incompetent.
We're arguing that, first of all,
he didn't have an intent
to murder Antonio.
His intent was to rebel, to
protest against this circumstance
that he found himself in.
And on the second point, that even
if the court were somehow to find
that he had an intent to
murder, there's no act.
There's no act of actually
doing anything.
He can't be convicted for
murderous words any more
than anyone else could
saying, "I want to do this."
I mean his situation, Your
Honor, would be comparable
to a murder trial where a parent
comes in, and says to the court,
"This man should be executed."
And then that person
was arrested for murder.
I mean that would be a
relatively similar situation.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: I thought
you started out with the point
that he couldn't be tried for murder
when all he did was bring a
civil suit to enforce a contract?
>> Michael Klotz: Yes, Your Honor.
[ Laughter ]
No, I think both things are true.
I think that it's totally
inappropriate, and it makes,
you know, it's totally
inappropriate that any request
of a court could be a criminal act.
And, so, for that reason I
don't think it's possible
to convict him under the Alien Act.
I don't think there's any way
that this can be attempted murder.
And, separately, in a
not inconsistent point,
he didn't do anything.
I mean during this scene he
had a knife, and he, you know,
he said some words
that he may regret.
[ Laughter ]
But nothing else happened.
>> Richard Schneider:
But the question
of motive is important to us.
It's important in terms of
thinking of what Shylock did,
and how we should rule here.
I mean one motive is revenge.
You know, which obviously would
be caught up with the murder.
But you make an argument
in your brief,
and that you just mentioned a
minute ago, that Shylock was in fact
in a sense rebelling
through this contract.
I'm not sure I really
understand what you mean by that.
Maybe could you elaborate a
little bit on that for us?
What do you mean?
What was Shylock doing
here if it wasn't revenge?
>> Michael Klotz: Yes, Your Honor.
So I mean the attempt to enforce the
penalty provision was a rebellion
against the Venetian laws that
treated him so differently.
And then this is the one area
where he was able to do something.
You know, he was able to sort
of set the terms of his life.
And the other part of it is during
the proceeding what Shylock points
out about Antonio and the
other Venetian merchants is the
incredible hypocrisy.
You know, Venetian capitalism, you
know, there's trade in many things,
but one of the main aspects
of trade was slavery.
And, so, it seems very hypocritical
and improper that merchants
like Antonio should be able
to grow wealthy selling
people against their will.
And my client should not be able
to recover the penalty provision
even though there's a, you know,
there's a physical component to it.
[ Inaudible Speakers ]
>> Connie Morella: You know,
I'm trying to understand
that there was a contract.
They actually made a legal contract
even though Shylock said something
about it being a merry
joke or something,
which meant that they fully expected
the money would be returned on time.
But then he perseveres
for the pound of flesh.
But then when he finds out
about the blood, you know,
and he says he wants it by a heart.
Did he think it could be
done in some other way
so that Antonio would not die?
I mean what did you find
out in your investigation
of this case what he had in mind?
>> Michael Klotz: Shylock
didn't intend to murder,
and did not intend
to murder Antonio.
It was a pound of flesh.
It was not a dagger in the
heart or anything like that.
>> Connie Morella: He
wanted it near the heart.
And, yeah--
>> Michael Klotz: He
wanted it near the heart.
But the court doesn't know any more
than I do if he'd been granted that,
if Portia had granted him
that right, and she'd enforce
that right of specific performance.
He might have dropped the knife,
and asked for the money instead.
I mean there's no way
to know at this point.
>> Connie Morella: Mr. Klotz,--
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: In any
case the money we have settled,
the pound of flesh is
out of the case now.
It's just a matter of money.
>> Michael Klotz: Yes, Your Honor.
No, we're not seeking
the pound of flesh.
And after all this time we're not
trying to cut, we're not trying
to come and have that be enforced.
>> Suzanne Reynolds: But if
you're seeking, Mr. Klotz,
if you're just focusing
on the civil action,
and you're not seeking
the pound of flesh,
you're seeking only the repayment
of the money plus interest,
isn't this a claim not raised below?
This is an appellate court.
Did you raise this claim below?
[ Laughter ]
>> Michael Klotz: That's a
great question, Your Honor.
[ Laughter ]
>> Suzanne Reynolds: Thank you.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: I take it
you're seeking a substitutional
remedy since the one you asked
for the law did not permit.
>> Michael Klotz: Well,
what I think, Your Honor,
is I mean the proceeding
obviously was totally improper
with Portia acting as the judge.
But the other main point that
we haven't discussed yet,
but is discussed in the brief,
is the incredible duress
for my client during the proceeding.
First Portia says, you know,
"You can get the pound of flesh.
You don't get blood.
You don't get any more
or less than that."
Shylock then asked for the
money, and was told no.
Portia then said that he
violated the Alien Act supposedly
for making this request
of the court.
And then Shylock was forced
to convert to Christianity.
And the Duke said very
clearly if he didn't do
that then he was going
to be executed.
So to the extent that
there's a waiver argument,
I think that maybe we
can let that slide.
[ Laughter ]
But we're asking this
court in addition,
to follow up on your point,
besides the civil remedy,
which is the return of the
3,000 ducats and the interest,
we're asking to have my client's
name cleared after all this time.
There's nothing that, you know,
there's nothing that we can do
about this improper
verdict other than to,
you know, completely nullify it.
>> Richard Schneider: You made
a comment about the Alien Act.
Are you arguing that
the Alien Act in itself,
and maybe you could explain exactly
what that is, but the Alien Act,
are you arguing that that
is somehow illegitimate,
or are you just simply saying it
was wrongly applied to Shylock?
>> Michael Klotz: The Alien
Act is totally illegitimate.
I mean it's an act that has
completely disparate treatment
of a certain group of people.
It protects Venetian
citizens in a way
that non-citizens would
not be protected.
If somebody were to have made
an attempt to murder my client,
Shylock, that wouldn't
have been a violation.
And nothing would have
happened whatsoever.
And just to give an example from
our case, you know, the Duke saying
to Shylock, "If you don't
convert to Christianity I'm going
to execute you," you know,
that seems very similar.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: But didn't
you consider that the only chance
that Shylock had for salvation,
so far from being a penalty,
it was a tremendous advantage
to Shylock to be converted
to a Christian, so then
his soul could be saved.
[ Laughter ]
>> Michael Klotz: You're
absolutely correct, Your Honor.
I think that's what he believed.
>> Richard Schneider: But, in other
words, the Duke was acting very,
the Duke was acting mercifully.
And Shylock, who Portia begged
to act mercifully, never did.
Shylock refused up
until the last minute
to renounce the pound of flesh.
>> Michael Klotz: We can't dispute,
Your Honor, that Shylock didn't act
with all the mercy that he
could have in this proceeding.
But I believe that the factors
that we've talked about, you know,
the treatment that he experienced.
His view that if he
doesn't have his rights
under the contract what
rights does he have?
He's already treated in this
totally unfair and disparate way.
And, you know, the
audacity of Antonio to act
as though this penalty
provision that he'd agreed upon,
and they talked about in detail,
and they'd negotiated, and they'd,
you know, reduced to writing,
was somehow an outrage.
And Shylock was, you know,
beyond the pale in trying
to enforce the terms
that they had agreed on.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: Do you say
he did not violate the alien rule
because he didn't actually
perform anything against Antonio,
even though he may have wanted to?
>> Michael Klotz: That's
exactly right, Your Honor.
>> Richard Schneider: Okay.
Your time is almost up, so do you
want to just quickly sum up and--
>> Michael Klotz: Yes, Your Honor.
To reiterate, we asked
the court to once
and for all vacate the decision
below without leave for a retrial
of my client, that the 3,000
ducats be returned in full,
that he be awarded interest on
that money after all this time,
and that the court
awards such further relief
as you think is appropriate,
particularly in light of what he
and other Jewish residents
in Venice suffered.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
Thank you, Counsel.
>> Michael Klotz: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: We will now
hear for Counsel for the Merchant
of Venice, Antonio, and
the Republic of Venice.
>> Eugene Gulland:
Thank you, Your Honor.
And may it please the
court, I want to begin
by rejecting the transparently
false narrative
that we've been presented with here.
The notion that Shylock was
engaged simply in a noble
and honorable protest of what he
thought to be the deficiencies
and unfairness of Venetian
law, that is simply not true.
Never until this appeal
have we heard that argument.
And indeed if we look at the
record of the case, again and again
and again it shows that Shylock
entered into a premeditated
and deceitful course of action
in order to lure Antonio
into sealing a bond that would be
the means of his own destruction.
And there are four critical
elements in this scheme.
They're undisputed in
the record of the case.
First, throughout Shylock
admitted to his motives.
Even before he negotiated the
penalty bond, he was overheard
to say quote, speaking of Antonio,
I hate him for he is a Christian.
If I can catch him once on the hip,
I will feed fat the
ancient grudge I bear him.
In fact we heard Shylock himself a
few minutes ago say that the pound
of flesh would be used
to bait fish withal.
And that further he would use that
pound of flesh to feed his revenge.
Other evidence of the
motive of revenge
and hatred abounds throughout
the record of this case.
But if there were any doubt
it would have been satisfied
when at his trial, in response
to questions by the Duke,
he explained that his motive
was a, quote, lodged hate
and a certain loathing,
end quote, for Antonio.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: Counsel,
before we get into your discussion
of the merits of a criminal
prosecution, I think you conceded
at the outset that that turn of
the proceedings from a civil suit
to enforce a contract
into a criminal case was
highly inappropriate.
Did you not make that
concession in your brief?
>> Eugene Gulland: Well, I
think we have two responses
to that, Your Honor.
The first is that Antonio
was permitted to use
as a counterclaim [inaudible]
a defense any law
that would be available--
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
Can you bring--
>> Eugene Gulland: To him.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
Can you bring in a civil
case a criminal prosecution
as a counterclaim?
>> Eugene Gulland: Yeah, absolutely.
Under the--
[ Laughter ]
Under the law of Venice
at that time this kind
of pleading was recognized.
But, as we argued in our brief, Your
Honor, we have an additional point.
And that is we do agree
on one point with Shylock.
And that is that the
procedures were flawed by reason
of Portia's misrepresentations
in masquerade.
And for that reason we've asked this
court to consider the case de novo.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: Well,
we have as Judge [inaudible]
reminded us, that this is a court
of review, not of first view.
De novo, we would be looking at the
case as a court of first instance.
But we are an appellate forum.
So we have no authority
to hear witnesses.
We judge the case according
to the law.
So I don't understand how you
could ask this court to serve
as a first instance, de novo court.
>> Eugene Gulland: Well, even
if this court should decline
to consider the case
entirely anew, the opportunity
through representation by very
able counsel, and the opportunity
to make all of his arguments ensures
that Shylock now has the right
to argue against the application
of the alien law to him.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: And
with the proceeding is improper,
then I suppose an appellate
court should just dismiss it.
And if it dismisses the
case and then where are we?
>> Eugene Gulland: Well, if this
court simply dismissed the case,
then I think it would put
Antonio and the Duke of Venice
in the position that they would want
to be in, because it would deny any
and all relief to Shylock.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: But you
are not urging us to do that,
because you recognize that
he did not get a fair trial.
Is that it?
>> Eugene Gulland: We regret
that the procedures were
not fair procedures.
Yes.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
Let me go to what seems
to be your principle
argument that this was an act
of vengeance on Shylock's part.
But Shylock, when the
transaction took place,
called it a merry sport,
a merry bond.
And a really puzzling aspect of your
position that it's all vengeance,
at the time this bargain was made
Shylock had every reason to think
that Antonio, rich
merchant Defendant,
would be able to repay him.
He had no idea of the
supposed tragedy at sea.
He expected, as Antonio
did, that Antonio would be,
his wealth would be increased
well within the time of the loan.
>> Eugene Gulland: I
think the record shows
that from the very beginning Shylock
was scheming to trap Antonio.
He deceived Antonio.
He said to Antonio, at the time
that they were discussing the bond,
that he was offering the loan for
reconciliation and friendship.
He said, quote, I would
be friends with you
and have your love, to Antonio.
As you point out, he
jovially referred
to the penalty bond
as a merry sport.
And he quickly added
that it was worthless.
Nobody could expect him to ever
claim the bond, because a pound
of a man's flesh taken from a man
is not estimable, profitable neither
as flesh from muttons,
beefs and goats.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: But
what basis did Shylock have
to even suspect that this
question would arise,
to suspect that Antonio would
not be able to repay him?
Antonio is a rich merchant.
There was no premonition
of storms at sea.
Why would you attribute to
Shylock such a motive of vengeance
when Shylock had every
reason in the world to expect
that within the three-months'
time he would be repaid?
>> Eugene Gulland:
He was laying a trap.
He understood that he
would probably be repaid.
But he also understood
that if he were not,
this would be his opportunity
finally to have the revenge
that he sought so dearly.
And there's a little noticed fact
that is very interesting
in this case.
And that is when he first
heard about the opportunity
to have a penalty bond from
Antonio, he didn't have the money.
Shylock didn't have the money.
And, so, what did he do?
He went to his moneylender friend,
Tubal, and borrowed the money
to lend in order to
get the penalty bond.
In other words, he was willing
to pay interest to Tubal,
and make a loan free of charge.
Free of charge.
And that was to set up the trap.
And it shows that throughout, from
the very beginning to the very end,
that even though he recognized
that he would probably be
repaid, the trap could be set.
And he would have his
revenge if he was not repaid.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
One other thing
that Shylock was very clear
about, he said it a few times,
he said, "I crave the law."
But no one told him
what the law was.
Nobody told him about the Alien Act.
So it's an obvious case of
no notice or opportunity
to rethink the case
in light of the law.
But Shylock craved the law.
Once he's told what the law is, then
the pound of flesh is off the table.
>> Eugene Gulland: The pound
of flesh is not a valid
penalty bond under Venetian law.
Venetian law, it's true,
enforced commercial terms.
The penalty bond here is
not a commercial term.
In fact Shylock himself
admitted many times
that it was not a commercial
term when he said
that he would gladly give up
repayment of 20 times the loan
in order to enforce
the penalty bond.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
But what about the state
of mind of your client, Antonio?
Why did he agree to this so swiftly?
>> Richard Schneider: And
just to follow up on that,
I have a problem with that as well.
I mean it's not hard for me
to understand why Shylock
would want this bond,
whether we think it was revenge or
whether we think it was, you know,
political expression of some sort.
But why would Antonio agree
to be bound by this bond?
Why would he agree to give up
a pound of his own flesh just
to get money for Bassanio?
And what I'm thinking here
is really is it possible
that Antonio was the one
laying the trap for Shylock,
because Antonio knew that Shylock
would be hit with the Alien Act?
>> Eugene Gulland: Well,
there's no evidence
in the record to suggest
[inaudible]--
>> Richard Schneider:
Well, there may not be--
[ Laughter ]
There may not be reference
to the record to that.
But I'm just speculating.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: Well, may--
>> Eugene Gulland: The fact--
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
May I interject
that there are multiple
clues in the record.
When we first meet
Antonio he said, "In sooth,
I know not why I am so sad."
He later says, "I am tainted wether
of the flock, meetest for death."
Meetest for death.
So this is a very sad man
who is longing for death.
[ Laughter ]
>> Eugene Gulland: I think he
snapped out of that depression.
[ Laughter ]
To answer the question,
Antonio was fooled.
He was taken in by the
reconciliation and friendship
that he thought were
being offered by Shylock.
And in fact Antonio, just as he was
going and sealing the bond, said,
quote, there is much kindness
in the Jew, end quote.
And I have to say,
although he's my client,
that Antonio was easy
prey in another sense.
He was a profoundly, extravagantly
proud man with an extravagant
and exaggerated sense of honor.
And Shylock, cunning as he was,
preyed on this character
defect of Antonio.
And he did so in the following way.
He recognized that if it ever came
time to enforce the penalty bond,
that Antonio would be too
proud to dishonor it, that,
in other words, he would admit it.
And that's exactly what happened.
Antonio didn't hire a lawyer.
Antonio offered no defense.
Antonio confessed the bond, and
offered himself up to be killed.
And that's exactly what
Shylock's scheme was.
He knew that Antonio
would not resist,
and that there would be no
genuine court proceeding standing
between himself and his
opportunity to kill Antonio.
And that's why the argument
that there was an intercession
of a court proceeding as a defense
doesn't work, because Shylock,
taking advantage of
this character flaw,
knew that there would be no
meaningful judicial protection
of Antonio.
>> Connie Morella: Speaking
of being taken advantage of,
don't you think Shylock was in a way
in that he never got due process?
He never had anybody to advise him
of what the consequences would be,
or what the journey through
the law would mean for him.
Is it not amazing to you that
you take a civil case and it ends
up being a criminal case?
And, so, should he not have been
given due process along the way?
>> Eugene Gulland: Well,
let's take it in steps.
In the negotiation
of the penalty bond,
I think that Shylock is a
very experienced moneylender,
was very knowledgeable
about the applicable law.
And it shows that regardless
of the criticisms,
we have the Venetian law, court
proceedings were open to Jews
in Venice, and the protection of
the laws were applicable to them.
You are right that when his
case got to court, the charade,
Portia's masquerade, did
deny him due process.
And we entirely agree with that.
We think, however, though
on the basis of the record
and the devastating admissions
repeatedly made by Shylock,
that he properly stands
convicted of the offense
of which he was found guilty.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: But how does
the Alien Act come into the picture?
You just said that Antonio
wasn't putting up any defense.
He certainly didn't
raise the Alien Act.
It was this sham lawyer/judge,
Portia, who brought that.
>> Eugene Gulland: Well, our brief
points out that the intervention
of Portia indeed saved
the life of Antonio.
It also saved the life of Shylock.
And it saved Shylock because
Shylock was ready, willing
and able to kill Antonio.
The notion that Antonio
would have been spared
by Shylock is absolutely crazy.
The record shows Shylock was
earnestly sharpening his knife
in the court, that Shylock
had a balance scale in order
to measure the pound of flesh.
He was ready to do it.
And it was only Portia
that saved Antonio,
and also saved Shylock from himself.
>> Suzanne Reynolds: Counselor,
I'd like to ask a question here.
I think we'd all agree that the
record is beautifully written.
[ Laughter ]
But that it's rather thin, at
least of the court proceeding.
And I believe that you are
asking us to draw a lot
of inferences from the record.
What about this inference
that Shylock never believed
that the court would allow him
to exact his pound of flesh?
He does seem surprised
in the court proceeding
when Portia says, "You're right.
You may enforce the penalty bond."
And he praises her, and
sounds very surprised.
Why isn't it, as reasonable
inference as you would have us draw,
that he was willing to put
the knife to Antonio's heart?
Why isn't it equally a valid
inference that he never thought
that the court would allow
him to exact this measure?
Enforced the penalty bond literally?
>> Eugene Gulland:
Well, with all respect,
we don't think there's
any question of inference,
because we have the man's words.
Again and again and
again, those words, events,
nothing other than an intent to
execute Antonio, to have revenge,
and to realize the
longstanding object of his hatred,
that is the killing of Antonio.
>> Suzanne Reynolds: But
that's another inference.
I mean as Justice Ginsburg
pointed out, he did say,
Shylock said on several
occasions, "This is a merry bond.
This is nothing to
be worried about."
And he does appear surprised
when Portia says, "You're right.
You win." Why is it not a
proper inference for us to draw
that he might have, since you
want us to draw some inferences
from the record, why
isn't it appropriate
to draw that inference as well?
>> Eugene Gulland: As I read
the record, beautifully written
as it is, I'd characterize
Shylock's reaction not
as surprised, but as
exultant delight.
[ Laughter ]
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: Counselor,
your time is about to run out,
so if you would like to--
>> Eugene Gulland: Thank you.
We, for the reasons argued in
our brief and the arguments
that I would have made if I not
had so many good questions,--
[ Laughter ]
We believe that the
judgment below was correct,
and that this court should arrive
at the same judgment
on its own initiative.
Thank you.
>> Richard Schneider:
Including conversion.
>> Eugene Gulland: Absolutely
including conversion.
That's to save the
eternal soul of Shylock.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: We will
now hear from Portia's Counsel.
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns:
Justice Ginsburg,
and may it please the court,
I am Teresa Miguel-Stearns,
Counsel for Appellee, Portia.
Some 400 years ago Portia provided
legal advice to the Duke of Venice
in a commercial contract dispute
between Appellant Shylock
and Co-Appellee Antonio.
This commercial contract
dispute almost turned deadly.
Portia's skillful navigation of
Venetian law saved both men's lives.
As a direct result in her role
in this Shylock/Antonio dispute,
Portia has suffered unjustified
targeted attacks to her reputation
over the course of
the last 400 years.
[ Laughter ]
Today, Portia asks that she
be discharged from this case,
and from any future
related proceedings.
[ Laughter ]
Your Honor, we have five
points to our brief.
However, the heart of our
argument is first and foremost
that Portia is the wrong
Defendant Appellee in this case.
And, secondarily, that Portia's
alleged misrepresentations
to the court, and alleged interest
in the outcome of this matter,
are without merit, or
at most harmless error.
[ Laughter ]
And I will turn to
those matters now.
First, Portia is the wrong
Defendant Appellee in this case.
Counsel for Shylock is
well aware that the Duke
of Venice ruled the city
in the 16th century.
Portia's role was merely to provide
legal advice to the Duke of Venice,
who was the ultimate
arbiter in this case.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: But Portia,
although she was not a lawyer,
we can recognize that she
knew something about the law.
And surely she would have known that
for her, for Portia, to give counsel
to the Duke, and to Shylock
to stand there unrepresented,
which he was willing to do
when he was a Civil Plaintiff
being prosecuted, and no counsel,
apart from your conflict
of interest being married
to the principle debtor,
isn't that just overwhelming?
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns: Your
Honor raises three points.
And I would like to
address them all.
First, that Portia was
not learned in the law.
The record demonstrates that Portia
was indeed learned in the law.
And in 16th century Venice,
one did not need a university
diploma, or any time--
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
[inaudible] conceding
that she was learned in the law.
Maybe I misspoke or
you misunderstood.
Portia is learned in the law.
She had to be to be
such a trickster.
[ Laughter ]
But she is displaying her
learning for the benefit
of Republic of Venice and Antonio.
And Shylock is standing there
with no one to represent him.
He is the target of a
criminal prosecution.
Doesn't he have a right to Counsel?
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns: Your
Honor, on the issue of notice,
it was Shylock who dragged
everyone into court.
Bassanio, the Duke of Venice and
others tried to convince Shylock
to settle this case amicably
and financially prior
to coming to court.
But Shylock craved his bond.
Shylock wanted his pound of flesh.
So he brought everyone into
court on a civil proceeding.
This case never turned
in to a prosecution.
Portia was never a Prosecutor.
And the Alien Act remained
a civil forfeiture case.
As soon as Portia explained to the
Duke of Venice what was involved
in the Alien Statute, before
Shylock had to utter a word,
the Duke of Venice immediately
said, "No, we are not going
to consider this capital
punishment case.
We will keep it as a
civil forfeiture case."
And Shylock's estate was
the only thing in jeopardy.
Shylock's life or freedom were never
in jeopardy throughout the
course of these proceedings.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
But Shylock never knew
that the law put him
in that position.
He said repeatedly,
"I crave the law."
Had he been counseled, he would
have known what the law was
and escaped the forfeiture.
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns:
Respectfully, Your Honor,
ignorance of the law is no defense.
[ Laughter ]
And in this matter--
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
But having no Counsel
to tell him what the law was.
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns:
Your Honor, respectfully,
many people tried to convince
Shylock to settle this case prior
to it becoming the civil forfeiture
case required by the Alien Act.
In fact when Portia first
encountered Shylock,
when she entered the courtroom,
she said, "Who is the Jew
and who is the merchant?"
She placed both people, both
participants in this trial,
at the same level in
the eyes of the law.
She treated--
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
Who was the Jew,
not who is the lender
and who is the borrower.
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns: Right.
That's correct, Your Honor.
This is--
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: And that--
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns: This
is what the transcript shows.
[ Laughter and Applause ]
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: We have
another clue to Portia's character.
So she calls Shylock a Jew.
Back in Belmont when
Morocco appears, she said,
"We don't need people of
that dark complexion."
So we know that this is a woman
who entertains certain biases.
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns:
Your Honor,
Portia had a very distinct
idea in Belmont
that she wanted to marry Bassanio.
They had laid eyes on
each other in the past.
And she was hoping that
Bassanio would be the suitor
who would correctly guess
the box, the casket,
that her father laid out.
>> Richard Schneider: Was Portia
free to marry anybody she wanted to?
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns:
No, she was not, Your Honor.
Portia was a wealthy orphan
whose life was dictated
by her late father.
Her late father had
provided for her education,
but had also provided the method for
dictating who her husband would be.
And--
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: That
may have been very patriarchal.
But she spoke about
Morocco's burnished skin.
Her love for Bassanio
surely did not require her
to so disparage people from Morocco.
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns:
That's correct, Your Honor.
[ Laughter ]
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
So we recognize
that she has certain
biases based on race
against Morocco, against Shylock.
>> Connie Morella: I
would pick up on that.
I see that clearly as
a conflict of interest.
[ Inaudible Speaker ]
>> As a conflict of interest.
The unclean hand, because
of, you know, Bassanio,
and she was to gain
from the situation.
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns: Yes.
Regarding the conflict of
interest, Portia is alleged
to have had both a financial
and a personal conflict of--
>> Connie Morella: Right.
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns:
Interest in this case.
I will address both.
First, the financial
conflict of interest.
From the very beginning
Portia offered her own ducats
to settle this case with Shylock.
Even before she and Bassanio were
married, she offered her ducats
to Bassanio to help
settle this case amicably.
When Portia first walked into
court, she pleaded with Shylock
to settle the case financially.
Two times the amount, three times
the amount, ten times the amount
of ducats, of her ducats,
were offered to Shylock
to settle this case.
He refused.
She brought in the Quality of
Mercy speech where she says,
"The quality of mercy," excuse me,
"The quality of mercy
is not strained.
It droppeth as the gentle rain from
heaven upon the place beneath."
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
And where was her mercy?
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns:
Your Honor,--
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
That's a little bit later.
She is urging Shylock,
"Be merciful."
And then she turns on him and
said, "I have no mercy for you."
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns: I
believe Your Honor is referring
to the Alien Act.
And it is actually Portia's mercy
which saves both of their lives.
Portia is merely providing legal
advice to the Duke of Venice.
When Portia realizes that she is not
able to convince Shylock to amicably
and financially settle this case,
she grants him specific
performance on the contract.
And that is to take
the pound of flesh.
But at the moment that Shylock is
ready to carve out a pound of flesh
from Antonio's chest,
Portia stops the proceeding,
strictly interprets the
contract, which the reference
that was made earlier, in
that a strict interpretation,
the contract would require no more,
no less than a pound of flesh,
and not any other matter.
No blood, no other
matter, no bone, no organ.
At that point, she also advises
the Duke that Shylock's actions,
Shylock's attempt to murder Antonio,
which is not in doubt at this point,
is punishable by the Alien Statutes.
The Alien--
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: You're
telling us then that the contract,
it was impossible to
enforce the contract.
So the pound of flesh has
to go by impossibility.
Everyone knows you can't take
flesh without blood as well.
So then what would happen if he
can't get the remedy he's demanding,
he would get a substitutional
remedy.
He would get the ordinary
remedy for breach of contract.
That is in this case his money back.
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns:
Your Honor, respectfully,
this contract was enforceable
under the laws of Venice.
This is a commercial contract.
And Venice, as the international
commercial hegemony that it was,
required strict enforcement
of all commercial contracts.
The Duke knew this.
Antonio knew this.
Antonio even said this to his
friends as he was going into court--
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
But if Portia--
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns:
That the con--
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg: Is
correct, the contract is impossible
to enforce, because you can't
take flesh without taking blood.
It's an impossibility.
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns: Your
Honor, it is my understanding
that with a very hot knife one--
[ Laughter ]
One can take flesh without blood.
Your Honor, Portia's interest
in this case was to make sure
that both men walked out
of the courtroom alive,
not one on a stretcher having his
chest carved out and bled to death,
and not the other being dragged off
to the hangman's gallows
to meet his own demise.
This is the sign of a merciful
judge, not a conflicted one.
>> Suzanne Reynolds:
Miss Miguel-Stearns,
I believe it's your position
that Portia did not engage
in any misrepresentation.
Is that right?
You've certainly pointed
to facts in the record
that do support the conclusion that
she was very learned in the law.
But didn't she engage
in misrepresentation?
And, if so, doesn't that
taint the proceeding
so that the judgment
should be set aside,
and there should be a retrial?
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns: Your
Honor, the only misrepresentation
that Portia made was
disguising herself as a man.
That she was a woman had
absolutely no bearing
on the outcome of the case.
She was legitimately in the
court having been sent there
by Dr. Bellario to provide legal
advice to the Duke of Venice.
The Duke of Venice did not
want to enforce the contract,
even though he felt he needed to,
because the laws of Venice need
to be strictly enforced in order
to retain it's, as I mentioned,--
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
But did Bellario know
that Portia was married to the
principle debtor in this case?
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns:
Your Honor,
the record is not clear
on that point.
[ Laughter ]
However, Dr. Bellario did know
that Portia was learned in the law
and very capable of providing
appropriate legal advice
to the Duke.
Dr. Bellario wrote a letter
personally to the Duke,
and attested to the Duke that he
and Portia had reviewed the facts
of the case, had turned
over many books together.
They had reviewed the
appropriate law in this matter.
And that Dr. Bellario furnished
Portia with his opinion,
which on top of Portia's
own legal acumen,
would provide superb advice
to the Duke of Venice.
Dr. Bellario knew that she was
going to disguise herself as a man.
And actually gave her
the robes to do so.
Dr. Bellario was a trusted legal
adviser of the Duke of Venice,
and he was ill that day, so
he sent Portia in his stead.
Portia had no conflict of
interest in this matter,
other than to see the
dispute resolved amicably,
and see both men alive.
>> Connie Morella: Did
she not at some point
at the end reject Shylock's
request for repayment?
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns:
Yes, Your Honor, she did.
And that is because multiple
times throughout the course
of the proceedings
Shylock had been offered
to settle the case financially.
At some point when he finally
said, "No, I demand my bond,"
and Portia advised that specific
performance would be the only
remedy, at that point any
negotiations are off the table.
Venice is a place of no take-backs.
You don't get two chances in Venice.
Once they passed the point
of settling the case amicably
and financially, that
door was closed.
There is no right to say, "Oh,
well, I guess I can't take my pound
of flesh, so, okay,
let's go back in time.
I'll take the money and leave."
That is just not, that is
just not the law in Venice.
>> Richard Schneider: Portia's
motivation to get involved in this,
I don't quite understand the
way you're characterizing it.
She decides to get
involved after she's heard
that Antonio has lost his ships.
She says that she decides
that she must help Antonio,
because Antonio must
be a wonderful person
since he's the best
friend of her husband.
And at that point she decides that
she's going to play this trick.
Doesn't that motivation
in and of itself show
that she is deeply
conflicted here in terms
of her interests in the matter?
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns:
Your Honor, as I've mentioned,
Portia is not conflicted
in this case.
It's true that Bassanio
and Antonio were friends.
But Portia had never met Antonio.
Portia had never met Shylock.
Portia was only concerned about
providing proper legal advice,
and ensuring that both men
walk out of this case alive.
>> Ruth Bader Ginsburg:
How can you say
that when the only reason
she went to Bellario,
and the only reason she
then went to Venice,
was in the interest of her husband?
>> Teresa Miguel-Stearns:
Your Honor, Portia,
as a woman in 16th century Venice,
had very limited opportunities
to pursue a career.
[ Laughter ]
This was an opportunity, not
only to save the life of a friend
of her husband's, but also to
put her legal education to use.
[ Laughter ]
She knew that Dr. Bellario,
her cousin,
would properly recommend her.
And Dr. Bellario would not
have recommend a cousin,
someone who wouldn't be able
to provide legal advice,
much less a female
cousin, to send into court,
putting his own reputation
on the line,
providing advice to
the Duke of Venice.
Dr. Bellario was a trusted
advisor of the Duke of Venice.
He was a career member
of the legal community.
And he would not have put his entire
career on the line for Portia.
Your Honor, I see my time is up.
[ Laughter ]
If I may just close by saying
that Portia requests, once again,
that she be discharged
from this case,
and relieved of any
liability in this matter.
Portia did not have a
conflict of interest.
Her appearance as a man did not
affect the outcome of this case.
She was qualified to
provide legal advice.
And, but for Portia's legal acumen,
Shylock would have murdered Antonio.
And Shylock himself
would have been executed.
Rather, Portia, despite
attempts over and over again
to convince Shylock to show
mercy, she saved both Shylock's
and Antonio's lives with her
skillful navigation of Venetian law.
But even if this court does not
agree that Portia acted sincerely,
Portia is the wrong Defendant
Appellee in this case.
The Appellee should be the
city state of Venice alone.
Portia was merciful.
And in that spirit
would be wholly in favor
of this court's reversing
the Duke of Venice's order
that Shylock convert to Judaism.
Just as Portia would
have liked to of freely
and openly practiced law
in 16th century Venice.
And, so, she persisted.
[ Laughter and Applause ]
Thank you for your generous time
and your merciful attention.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.